quarters of ramsay solutions it's the
ramsay show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth new work that they actually love
and create real amazing relationships dr
john deloney ramsey personality
number one best-selling author of the
book own your past change your future
and host of the dr john dolone show is
my co-host today we'll be taking your
calls at triple eight eight two five
five
two two five
well john
i don't get to say this very often
at home
and occasionally i could say it here
i was right
i was right we are in a recession
but barely
it's such a wimpy little recession it
doesn't even count it looks to me like a
rounding error it really is ridiculous i
mean so the a recession if you don't
know we've been laughing about this last
couple days because the white house you
know anytime somebody doesn't like a
term these days they just redefine it so
we made fun of you redefining anxiety
and
biden white house came out and tried to
redefine what a recession is and
you can't it's it's econ 101. they teach
you in your first week in class in
college i mean come on a recession is
two consecutive quarters of the gross
domestic product
which is the adding up of all the goods
and services produced in the united
states shrinking
it's a little bit less
two quarters in a row it receded like my
hairline yes okay that's what a
recession is it receded however this one
didn't recede nearly as far as my
hairline
okay this recession is such a joke
that it's not even a real recession it's
not even a good one i mean as it went
down like one and something one and a
quarter one and a half percent first
quarter
last quarter we got the numbers out just
a few hours ago
they it went down
nine
percent that's like a rounding error
this is like getting a ticket for going
71 in in a 70. it's like come on man i
was speeding 70 and a half that's right
i was speeding come on man
70.9 in the 70. oh this is ridiculous so
now the the uh democrats are all going
to run around in circles acting like
it's no big deal because it's really no
big deal uh and uh the republicans are
all going to scream at the top of their
lungs we're dying it's in a recession
biden has crashed the economy oh my god
and no neither one is true by the way we
are in a recession and the economy is
not good
but it is this is not like a hurricane
recession this is a
a light mist it's not like the last one
we experienced it's not even a real rain
storm in q2
when
it hit in 2020 right yeah we shut down
the world
and the economy completely shrunk by
like what uh 25 or 30 percent shrunk yes
during quarantine right because
everybody's sitting at home eating
donuts right donuts went up plexiglas
went up but everything else went down
right and so then they came out of their
caves and bought everything in sight and
the economy exploded by 35 the next
quarter so that was a bizarre thing in
2020 but what we are is we we are
experiencing a slower economy it's not
growing it's not a time of prosperity
for sure
but it is not chicken little you don't
have to get your helmet out it's just
0.9
i was telling rachel that it could have
been up like 0.2 i i mean the numbers we
were getting there's a lot of precursor
reports that come out that you can read
and so i was seeing the indicators i
knew it was going to be basically flat
yeah
but it could have been up 0.25 it could
have been up a quarter of a percent and
then we wouldn't technically been in a
recession which would be like
what 30.35
difference in where we are right and it
would have been reversed the the
the right would have been saying
but i mean it's really a recession and
the left was saying see look at how
wonderful we bailed it out right
and neither one is true okay it's not
the end of the world don't let the right
tell you that because they're trying to
win the midterms uh based on the
recession it they need to win it based
on something else because there's not
much of it in the left this is a wimpy
little misty math isn't real again tiny
recession okay so
so in all reality but but it does suck
because we're not booming okay so yeah
it's obviously when the economy is not
on fire all in all reality it's hurting
i'm just a guy with two little kids and
stuff's expensive stuff like that
what do i do that's inflation right this
means nothing as well that's helpful
like just a regular other than the
economy is not it's kind of
you know it's just it's going for a walk
it's not going for a run
gotcha you know and it's and it's a slow
walk
but it's not had a heart attack in an
icu either okay so there you go
stretch this metaphor all we can but but
you said something important for the
average guy like me this number means
nothing means nothing other than the
idea of the economy slow so turn the
news off the economy's slow yes okay but
it's not a deep dark
man i'm 62 years old i've seen some dark
recessions they're not fun right that's
a whole bunch of layoffs a bunch of
businesses aren't doing business so they
don't need people they're not buying
stuff because they're not doing business
so they're goods that they produce
they're not producing them because
they're not doing business and so it
slows down it's not good it's ugly
recessions are ugly uh but this one's a
joke
this one's just moderately unpleasant
but the uh uh
this one could get a date i mean it's
not really ugly right so
hey yes
this is a recession like me and you and
we both ended up getting married this is
good
this is good i could get a date
but i do get to tell rachel cruz i was
right
hey this is worth something because she
was dogging me on the air the other day
because i said it might be up a quarter
of a percent she said wait a minute
america he just said he might be wrong
it's like yeah right she'll calm down
yeah i could have been wrong but i
actually wasn't so i'm really kind of
basking in this a little bit because i
did call it a while back i thought we
were going into a recession and we did
but you said what it's such a joke it's
going to be a minority missed it as easy
as i hit it truthfully because it's
basically flat line it's just
right down the middle so that that's the
thing so you're going to hear this all
over the news and you're going to hear
the fed increase the interest rates
again yesterday to slow inflation which
is stupid on steroids they're screwing
around with the economy they need to
leave it alone let it heal itself it's
going to be all right but they're going
to mess this thing up
and uh just man when you start messing
with supply demand stuff and you start
messing and tinkering with pay no
attention to the man behind the curtain
yeah we can't complete a sentence it's
not a good thing okay so let me ask you
this so let's let's take this metaphor
because that's my bigger concern
um you have a couple and their marriage
it's fine things are fine and you're
going for a walk and you've got the one
person who's saying
hey we should probably talk last night
um you i just felt and the other
person's saying
i was in a bad mood
and we're gonna dig into this and well
what if we just we're gonna we're gonna
try to start well let's start doing this
together let's do this and we need to go
do this we should probably go sign up
for this and let's read this book to get
another person saying hey is he's tired
there comes a point when the
intervention becomes worse than anything
that was actually going on is there a
moment here so it's a long long
drawn-out analogy here got lost in your
analogy okay now i'm not caught up i got
it okay is in other words you know
you're making a mountain out of my wheel
can you can we tinker with this and the
tinker's gonna crash the car well it's
not gonna crash it but it could make it
worse instead of making it better
um you know it's just
their first rule is do no harm right and
so exactly take your hands off if you
don't know what's going on take your
hands off for a second the beautiful
thing about capitalism is it has a real
tendency to heal itself if you leave it
alone okay
like crooks they don't make it because
people quit doing business with them why
because they're they're crooks yeah then
eventually if your product is brakes on
you
if you if you if you make a crappy car
eventually people call it a pinto i mean
you know i mean
you know that that's eventually the
marketplace will punish you for being
stupid and it will cleanse itself
but then it does that with cycles as
well but god i'm mighty we have to mess
with it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john deloney number one best-selling
author
host of the dr john baloney show ramsey
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five
two two five how many times have you
found yourself saying one day
when thinking about a goal that you have
one day i'll be able to buy a house one
day i'll be happy with my career one day
i won't have to battle with anxiety one
day i will set some boundaries stop
waiting around whatever your one day is
you need to start right now and that's
why we created the smart conference
smart conference is a one day event
where we will tackle all the areas of
your life and guys let's face it we
could all use that kind of boost right
now you'll hear from the nation's top
thought leaders on money career mental
health relationships marriage and
leadership the event is hitting the road
and will be coming to dallas texas on
saturday october 22nd it is already 60
sold out event passes are selling fast
the vip and platinum are gone and you
can get general admission still for 39
dollars so dr john deloney will be
speaking rachel cruz ken coleman all
number one best-selling authors george
campbell christina ellis best-selling
author i'll be there i'm sold a couple
books too and i had a couple ideas in my
life not to mention our friends and
leadership experts from life church
life church is uh craig and amy
groschell they're gonna be speaking on
marriage and uh let me tell you guys
there's big surprises all day this is a
day-long event you will leave inspired
and smarter it's smart conference
october 22nd
so jump online at ramseysolutions.com
events get your event
passes right now john is with us to
start off this hour in cincinnati hey
john how are you
good how are you dave better than i
deserve what's up
so i'm going to give you a quick
background before i ask my question so
i'm 28
i have all my debt paid off except for
my house and my house is about to be
paid off here in about five weeks right
um i've
i've been
working a ton of overtime i've been
doing it going gazelle intense for about
three years now working average 70 hours
a week had a baby with my wife and
so my question really is is about what
kind of advice you give a young person
like me that's in my position because
i'm kind of lost uh on a and i don't
really have a path and i'm i'm starting
to be burned out um so
just looking for some advice
sounds like you got a path
just like you got several sounds like
you're a new father and you're a husband
and you're working to pay off some debt
and you're working a professional job
are none of these paths are you not
feeling a certain way cause unless you
get some pretty pretty important pretty
cool what path is missing
i don't know i just felt like i
worked so hard and now that i'm about to
cross this finish line with paying off
my house too
at such a young age i just feel like i'm
i'm really burned out and i can't light
the fire back in me and get me going
again okay number one you you don't need
a light of fire back in you you're fine
yeah um
number two we don't tell you to we don't
tell folks to do what you've done
um once you reach the baby step four we
don't say gazelle intense anymore we
move from intense to intentional
and work to
systematically more of a marathon than a
sprint
be putting money in your retirement be
putting money in your kids college and
systematically paying off your house but
70 hours a week to stay gazelle intends
to pay off your house is not what we
tell folks to do it's okay that you did
it you didn't do anything wrong
but uh no wonder you're burned out in
other words you fried yours you fried
your brain man you put it on the egg and
put it on the skillet on the uh on the
dadgum uh stove so
you know let's just say hey let's uh
work 40 hours a week
uh
systematically save for retirement
save for my kids college
increase my generosity
and um go on a vacation take go on a
vacation put your feet up
rock the baby
oh my gosh i mean what's wrong with that
number um what are you what are we
missing here you need a new goal is that
what you're saying no i
yeah sort of a new goal um i just feel
like after i've
done this i'm just kind of settling and
i don't know if that's what i'm saying
no you're not sure
so okay so you've seen the the marathon
pictures where the runner comes across
the finish line and collapses at the
marathon
yes
you see the finish line and you're about
to cross it and your body is failing you
as it should after you run an olympic
marathon and you're thinking what
workout can i get in tonight because i
don't want to waste this evening
and what every coach and trainer on the
planet would say you need to take a
couple weeks off
take some time i said rejuvenate relax
your next goal and mission and purpose
and thing it'll come to you man
that's just who you are you're a driven
guy you're gonna go make it happen
you're not settling
you are leaning into rest you're leaning
into peace there's a reason why you did
all this it's so you can put your feet
up and go so you can give like crazy
you're there now and you're gonna have
to practice what that feels like because
you've never experienced that
it's an it's all new feeling what what
we're saying is is there is as much
dignity in running a marathon as there
is a sprint
and right now you think the only thing
that is that is worthy is sprint so if
i'm not sprinting i'm settling
i see and you're playing a much
different longer game yeah play now
you're playing long ball man yeah
okay different game
and i'll tell you the key to all olympic
workouts is not the workout program it's
the rest program
it's teaching these olympic driven
athletes to put their feet up to rest to
take get some peace so that when they
get back into the game they are full in
i'm gonna throw a book at you all right
there's a girl an old book a buddy my
name bob buford wrote called half time
and the premise of the book
half time by bob buford the premise of
the book is that men in particular spend
the first half of our lives in
acquisition mode
the second half
in the in in search of significance
now this is in the case of a god with a
life well lived
okay but what happens sometimes to men
and you're not a candidate for this but
what what you've observed with maybe
friends that are a little bit older than
you or i have when i was in my 20s or 30
late 20s early 30s is a guy
will kind of be winning the quote
success game and it's not it's not
fulfilling because acquisition doesn't
fulfill there's only so much of that you
can you know eat enough lobster it
tastes like soap and so there's only so
much gathering of stuff that is
fulfilling after that you need
significance and so where you're going
to find great joy and depth
and
soul
refreshment is in working for
significance rather than
uh acquisition because what you've done
so far is an excellent job on the
acquisition stuff i mean crap man you
knocked out your house you're 28 years
old you killed it but now you got to
have something that's a little little
deeper a little more philosophical a
little more spiritual uh and if and the
guys that don't do that and again i'm
not accusing you of this but just for
the rest of your edification what
happens to guys is they just keep going
and going and going going think
acquisition acquisition acquisition and
then they get all this stuff and all
these these accolades and it's still not
enough and so that's when we then that's
when they have what we call a mid-life
crisis they go get other wives into
their homes
you know the red convertible and the
blonde secretary and here we go you know
and so or whatever the whatever the
stereotype is of a midlife crisis right
so um
uh no disrespect to your blind
secretaries but the uh but the uh uh oh
my gosh but uh you that's what happens
is you don't if you don't intentionally
change that gear
at that at that apex um your you will
fill it up with the wrong stuff here's a
fun uh adventure you and your wife can
go on um go to take a half day retreat
in the next week or two
and ask her this question
who do we want to become now that we've
done all of this another half day serve
soup at the homeless shelter there you
go and let's get up three or four books
that we want to read together over the
next few months as we start thinking
about who are we going to become and
also let's make service a regular part
of our marriage of our giving back to
our community that'd be incredible yeah
and yeah it's it is the best part of
life and it's the best part of money
yeah
actually is the live like no one else so
later you can live and give like no one
else you got to do that second part yeah
the live and give part you know enjoying
things and continuing to embrace things
and do things and
so forth and um you know as with a group
of guys last night one of the guys
said hey i want to ask you guys some
questions well couldn't we gather up and
i just yeah i don't want to use him for
that that's fun and
real philosophical thing kind of thing
on the back porch right but it was this
whole this whole idea that
you know what we what are we gonna do
now that matters
you know and man that's just
you gotta live a life with that kind of
intensity yeah that kind of
intentionality that's a different thing
that's where you are man you're in a
really good place and your question is
not weird it's an actually a very very
good question and a very good place that
you're in that you find yourself in but
be intentional about the next steps
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today nicole is in orlando hi
nicole how are you
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up
so i'm new to the dave ramsey i just
heard about you guys
about a week ago i've been living under
a rock
um but i um
i looked through the baby steps and i'm
kind of coming up with an issue right
now
um so my family um i was living in los
angeles california i sold my home
and with the profits i was able to
purchase a home outright in uh well we
live in kisame florida where i have a i
take i took a position that now has
doubled my income fabulous
so we are really needless to say we feel
incredibly blessed yeah but the problem
i'm having right now is um you know we
with the home we still have about a
hundred thousand dollars left over we
have about 150 000 between cash in the
bank and we also invested in gold
but my problem is my new employer we
don't have a 401k
and i don't qualify now for a roth so
i'm kind of getting a little nervous as
far as what to invest in what's the best
way to grow my money i'm 30 years old
right now and
so let me get this straight you're 100
debt free you don't owe on your house
you doubled your income
i don't think there's anything to be
nervous about except where we're going
to throw the party i mean you are really
doing it this is great
it's good for you
so um
not to make light of you or anything but
dave i might be wrong but should she buy
a bunch more gold
i i did buy some more but not like
he's being facetious don't listen to the
[ __ ] don't buy gold don't listen to him
we tell people not to buy gold so here's
the thing you are you are what we call
baby step seven
okay
all the baby steps leads you out of debt
while building an emergency fund while
starting your retirement while starting
your kids college do you have kids that
you need to save for college for
um yes i have one daughter she's 13 and
we have about 20 000 which was kind of
our yeah my husband i agree that was
kind of our max as far as what we wanted
to contribute put a little skin in the
game but she also has to have some skin
in the game yeah like a hundred and
fifty thousand okay uh a lot of skin
your daughter's gonna be putting in
there but anyway there's yeah i'm
probably doing a little more than that
if uh i'm gonna argue with you guys on
that even if you're not gonna pay for a
hundred percent that twenty thousand
ain't gonna touch it nope so um you need
to compress a collar
blow your mind but anyway the uh so
here's the thing you're at what we call
baby step seven which that step is build
wealth
and give
so i want you to make sure you're you're
doing all you can for retirement all you
can for the kids college a good way to
do that is to sit down with a good
financial advisor you can do a what's
called a back door
roth ira
and you can put 8 000 a year 6 thousand
a year seven thousand a year wherever
you are in the process they're into that
each
uh is your husband working outside the
home
uh no he's actually a paraplegic so i'm
the sole income provider
but you can but you can do a spousal ira
and a regular ira and they can be roth
iras and you can back door them okay
what a backdoor is it's called a
backdoor roth what you do is you open a
an after tax
traditional
ira and instantaneously roll it to a
roth
okay
i have a income that far exceeds the
limits and i do those every year
so it's perfectly legal it is a loophole
but it's perfectly legal and moral to do
that
and you put it in
good growth stock mutual funds like your
kids college should be in so we have
we're not in the investment business
around ramsey but we have a group of
investment advisors that we have vetted
all over america
many different brands meaning they work
for different companies but they all
share a couple of traits one they have
the heart of a teacher which you want to
learn about this stuff
and two
that they are going to give you advice
that's consistent with what you hear
around here and they're we call them
smart vesters
and you are you're the smart investor
they're the smartvestor pro
so you click on that at
ramseysolutions.com it'll give you a
list of three or four in your area you
can interview all of them and decide
which one you like
which one you feel good about and you
can do your roth backdoor roths there
you can soup up your kids college fund a
little bit in your 529 let's get that
thing moving a little bit better than it
is
and you can do some other type of
investing beyond that which you're going
to be able to do with your wonderful
income because you don't have any bills
way to go and they're going to tell you
what i'm going to tell you which is
don't invest in gold it's a bad
investment it's had a bad rate of return
over the last 70 years it's averaged
about 1.2 percent
gotcha now it's had some big years that
the gold bugs like to talk about but
it's had a lot of down years
and um it is basically a um it's a
commodity and commodities are not things
i invest in so you can do whatever you
want because that's what i would do i
have some gold cuff links and that's it
um
um yeah so yeah that's what i would do
the last thing you can do is what's
called a if you want to write this down
as a lo you got back door you got to
write down for roth the other one is a
low turnover mutual fund
and so i do a lot of those now too and
what that is is they don't sell the
stocks inside the mutual fund
much
so a low turnover ratio would be like a
four percent turnover ratio meaning only
four percent of them are sold in a year
so there's hardly any of the gains are
activated for taxes
so it works kind of like if you buy a
single stock let's say you bought a
stock of home depot for 50 bucks i don't
even know what home depot goes for but
let's say you bought it for 50 bucks if
it goes up from 50 bucks to 70 bucks you
don't pay any taxes on that 20 gain
until you sell it
because they're not selling the stocks
inside the mutual fund there's low
turnover it's growing like that stock
was growing and you don't pay taxes on
it until you sell it because they're not
selling it now if the mutual fund turns
over all the time it's activated even
though you didn't sell the mutual fund
it's still activating the gains and you
have to pay tax on it every year so you
want this is capital gains growth and
it's a good way to do that another
excellent way to get at that is just a
a no-load s p 500 fund will put you in
that same thing almost all of those are
low turnover ratio
so just check for the turnover ratio or
talk to your smartvestor pro about that
um i do some through my smart vista pro
and i just occasionally just dump some
into a into an index fund uh and what
i'm typically doing there nicole you do
whatever you want but i'm a real estate
goob so i'll just use that fund build it
up till i got enough money buy a piece
of real estate in it and then i'll cash
that in and go buy some real estate and
it's if i keep it longer than a year
it's taxed at capital gains rates to the
ordinary income rate which is half
15 for you 20 for me versus just on the
growth only on the growth yeah yeah so
um but it's an excellent vehicle for
uh because you get you know a better tax
deal if you hold it a year and you don't
pay taxes if you hold if you just keep
holding it just keeps growing so i
remember back in the early to mid 80s
dave my dad took me down when i started
my little lawn business and he took me
down to open up a savings account
and my interest rate was
11 12 13 we were coming out of this that
bad inflation i remember it and i
remember circling back in college
and getting a savings account and it was
one and i remember thinking the bank was
ripping me off and i didn't understand
about economics
can we expect with inflation with the
fed rates that we can go down to
normally we put money in index fund we
put it in a money market account can we
expect to go down to our banks and just
get these elevated rates that we haven't
experienced the last decade well fed was
running uh when as high as 18
the fed rate did in 1982
and under jimmy carter and it was out of
control yeah and so the fed the fed
that's an example of
government tinkering with the economy
that they shouldn't have been so they
ran the fed rate up i mean and what the
fed funds rate is is what one bank
borrows from another right so it's their
cost of money
so if they pay more to borrow money from
another bank to loan to you then they're
going to charge you more so industry
drives interest rates up to the consumer
so the fed funds rate's a big deal um
but no you know you'd have to say i
think interest rates in general the
interest rate environment is going to go
through the roof again and
i got to tell you man it got they got
carter booted out of office for sure
that in the iran hostage crisis cost him
the presidency
and he was a sitting president one term
yeah
and that's unusual
and it cost him that for sure as
political suicide to do that so no i
mean six percent federator you know i
mean a six percent mortgage market is
not a it's not a high mortgage market no
no it's not it's not it's not anywhere
near that kind of numbers so no you're
not going to see a savings account
that's going to pay much more than
one or two percent in
in your coming years
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john delaney ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america savis sylvester is in new haven
connecticut hi sylvester how are you
how are you doing
i'm doing mr deloney better than we
deserve sir how can we help
how you doing today sir i'm calling on
behalf of me and my wife um we just have
a question we would like to know should
we sell our home right now do
tensolation because it's up to pay off
like that
and move into apartments for two years
and just try to save for another house
it's my last choice if you can't do it
any other way
so uh how much do you owe on your home
um right now we all got 114 000. what's
it worth
right now about 205. and how much debt
have you got not counting the house
um the debt is 70k uh 40 40 student
loans which is my wife and she has
another 15 and personal and i have 10
personal so we're around 70s no car debt
no car that we don't know we own our car
they'll be activating another car
because we have two children yeah so
what uh what's your car worth
um
it's uh
um
um insurance won't consider the total
loss so they'll give us probably six
thousand for it they won't fix anything
on it so
we'll get six thousand of these
that's the one that totaled what's the
other one worth
no we don't have one we need an
additional car oh so you have one that
you're out of cars right now yeah we
just have one car one car but we need
another one every cell will be probably
able to get another car i got you okay
so what is your uh what's your household
income
um
honestly um i i make over six figures
with three incomes um
so my wife brings in maybe
um right now she's about to start a new
job which is around 60 so she averages
maybe 60 80 000 a year right now she's
trying to find so you have a household
income of like two hundred thousand
dollars
uh at least 180. yeah that's what i'm
thinking yeah so
no you don't need to sell your house
how long your wife your wife's not been
working until recently oh yeah she just
stopped and she's you know job searching
looking for the right job that you know
how long has she been out of work
um maybe the past two months you know
she just needed me time dealing with the
children and just you know no i'm just
i'm i'm not picking on her i'm just
trying to find out where these where
this math is going so basically you've
had over the last two or three years a
household income of 100 to 180 000
somewhere in there
i would say i was i i just got my high
school job this year so you could say
before that was w2s making 135 together
because we owe every year in taxes yeah
and now we're at 180s yeah well new
haven connecticut 200 000
for a house is not a fancy house
no it's a condo so that's why she she
would like to sell
take the game be debt-free i'll move
into an apartment with our children for
two years and hopefully buy another home
you know we're just asking for
recommendations because we spoke to
other financial advisors and he was like
uh use your line of equity yeah um you
know it's up to you so here's that
financial advisory yeah fire that person
so here's what you need to do i'm gonna
pick can i pick on you is that okay
absolutely so okay you make too much
money to be this broke y'all are
disorganized
out of control and overspending
you make a lot of money especially if we
get jacket all the way up to 180
thousand 180 thousand yeah will pay off
seventy thousand in about nine or ten
months
but you know i granted you've not made
180 through this whole story
while you got into this mess
but the way you knock this out is not
selling the house selling the houses the
the debt is not the problem it's the
symptom
and you're treating the symptom
when you sell your house i'd rather you
treat the problem which is you guys get
on a tight budget
no eating out
no vacations
no life
and you pay all of this off in nine or
ten months
i mean how would it feel to be ten
months from now have no debt but your
house
be great that's that's the ultimate plan
yeah and then guess what you can figure
it out yeah then that condo goes up in
value for the next couple years while
you're saving some more money to add
with that condo and you can move into a
little better house which is really what
your wife's trying to pull off here
without dealing with the fact that you
guys are overspending like you're in
congress
but you got to deal with that or dude
you're going to be broke your whole life
you can't out earn stupidity i tried it
for a long time
and you can't outlive disorganization
and i've tried that for a long time
there's a lot of stress in this story
isn't there sylvester
yeah my wife is extremely stressed
that's why i have a job searching yeah
hold on hold on hold on hold on hey
you're stressed too
i'm fine i'm fine honestly it's my wife
i care about and i love him i just want
to do that
on your sword if you want but dude the
numbers you're giving me are stressful
if you're working three jobs you you
think you kind of know what you're
making what you're not that's a that's
hard right and you're you're you're
you've got you're strong you you go to
work you work hard there's some ego
there but it's okay to say man i want to
live a more peaceful life too yeah if
you had no payments and all your money
was doing exactly what it was told
you'd be breathing deeper and one more
step you you mentioned your wife's got
some debt and you got some debt if you
were so in sync with her that this was
y'all's debt
and this will be y'all working together
on getting out of this thing and then
your marriage is you're gonna look up in
a year after grinding this thing out and
y'all will have accomplished a big hard
thing together and then your marriage is
going to be in a place that you didn't
you don't remember it being so here's
the deal you're a good guy i can tell by
talking to you absolutely you're a solid
guy
um and
uh i think you guys are almost ready to
do the smart stuff
if you are really ready
i'll give you financial peace university
the nine-week class for you to go
through you and your wife go through it
together
find a local church and plug into it or
get get on with an online group and go
through it with your online group and
then watch the videos and do the budgets
and do the stuff we teach you and in
literally in nine weeks i can show you
how this debt should be gone in nine
months and both of you be on the same
page
we can show you how to do it we've shown
10 million people how to do it
if i give that to you for free can you
get her to go along with you and the two
of you do these lessons together
well she's on the phone now if you don't
mind clicking in okay what's her name
what's her name
my name is does she know about all this
discussion we've just been having yes
sherry shay shay
yes hey i'm gonna give you guys
financial peace university if you'll
promise to actually go through it
together will you break that promise
yes if you guys will do this we can show
you how to get out of debt in nine or
ten months twelve months max and you
keep the condo let the condo go up in
value and then you can move over and
jump into the better house later on
that's about a three year plan or so
does that sound good
sounds good
okay you guys make too much money to be
this freaking broke you agree with that
absolutely all right you hang on austin
will pick up and we'll help you guys get
through this you're you're the kind of
people we like to help
yeah she's on the phone this is bad this
good good good news right here john i
know and i love
man if i'm smiling ear to ear i love
talking to husbands who
have run up against like i'm trying i've
tried to
flex my way through this and i need to
go ask somebody for another plan because
my plan of just go go go it's not
working
and i'm looking around i got a stressed
wife i've got strife kids i got debt
maybe maybe we can come up with a scheme
to get out of this and then i'm gonna go
to somebody and say hey i need some
wisdom and you say i got a path for you
that's got a path forward that's called
a good man it's called wisdom that's a
good man she married well good man
and she's a good lady she's yeah yeah he
jumped right in there i mean we have the
dragon kicking and screaming so this
this is the kind of folk that turn these
things they'll be on the stage doing a
debt-free scream in a year yep and um in
in five years they'll be telling me
their baby steps millionaires oh for
sure they're on their way because they
make 180 000. let me just tell you man
new haven connecticut not a cheap place
to live nope so um that's that's a big
market there so uh so it's a nice market
but um yeah wow wow very very cool and
i'd love to hear those three i'm working
three jobs and i'm making it happen here
i love it yeah it's just so interesting
that
98 of winning at this stuff is just
deciding to do it yeah
it's exciting i'm not gonna live like
this anymore so i was hiking the other
day um my wife and i were on our
anniversary trip i was hiking up a hill
and
i think mental health i think financial
health physical health i think if we
distill it all down it comes into
three words do it anyway
let's do it anyway it's hard i need a
plan just go do it do it anyway go do it
anywhere anywhere i don't wanna have a
conversation with good to have good
without art williams talk just do it
just yes just just do it do it
just on the right
love it i love it this is good stuff man
good stuff thank you guys for joining us
ah
thanks to austin ben zach andrew james
and
will in the booth
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love
and create actual amazing relationships
dr john deloney number one best-selling
author
host of the dr john dolone show ramsey
personality is my co-host today open
phones triple eight eight two five five
two two five lindsay's with us in
columbia south carolina hi lindsay how
are you
hey dave i'm doing great how are you
guys better than we deserve what's up in
your world
yeah so i just recently got engaged and
my fiance and i have been following your
baby steps for a few years now we are
debt free
um so now we are now planning and
budgeting for the wedding which we will
be able to cash flow
but yeah um but i
i am finding myself having a lot of
guilt um over
spending the money on the wedding um we
are both anticipating we are going to
need new cars soon we're at the phase of
our life where we'd like to start saving
for a down payment um i don't want to
jit myself of the wedding um that i want
but i am having
shame about wanting to spend so much
money well i mean it it
wouldn't be shameful or guilt-inducing
unless it is
too much money and and the way we how do
we say too much money it's in relative
terms
to your situation okay if you make two
million dollars a year
and you want to spend 50 grand on a
wedding that's not too much
if you make 40 000 a year and you want
to spend 50 grand on a wedding you're
crazy so what is it you want to spend on
the wedding
uh i think it's going to be about 25 to
30 grand tops nice wedding
and what is your what is your income
uh household income is probably about 90
000. well there's not a household yet
but yeah okay yeah yeah all right but
yeah that would be uh the numbers we're
dealing with anyway so
well the average
household
income in america right now is about 70
000 and the average wedding is about 25
000.
okay okay now so that that's the average
but we do want to keep in mind normal is
broke so we don't necessarily want to
aim at average but
the point of that is you're not
completely out of control
but now you start to make value
judgments and go
every five thousand dollars i cut this
accelerates
the other goals
and so it's the trade-off that you're
going to make the rest of your life if i
spend money on a i don't have it for b
it's called opportunity cost
and that's what i'm struggling with like
i don't want to have the wedding
and then
what i want you to do is set a plan set
a number
stick to that number
and never struggle again
okay now you should uh i i do want some
of this
negative emotion to keep you from
overspending your budget
and so what would i do if i woke up in
your shoes
i would probably say
you know we're i just don't feel okay
about 25 i'm because you're not feeling
okay about it
by the way i'm kind of kind of keying
off of that
okay it wasn't like you're going this is
because let me just tell you the
difference in twenty thousand dollar
wedding twenty five thousand dollar
wedding no one that visits will know
that's a napkin arrangement
that's the chairs you chose for the
reception you know i mean oh my god
so and then when you start laying out
the actual wedding budget
you know so you put a big number on it
and then you say based on that i'm gonna
spend x on the uh videos and pictures
i'm gonna spend y on the dress i'm gonna
spend z
on the uh
reception i'm gonna you know and every
one of the l the band the dj the the
preacher the whatever and you just line
item this out like it's a project
because i'm sorry darling but it is
and then you stick to that you say okay
i've got this much budgeted for catering
and they go well you can't get the sushi
if you do that well then we won't be
having sushi darling so this
no is a possible answer to some of these
questions
and so um but the the thing that will
give you great peace and no guilt is if
you'll set a number detail it out and
then stick to it you'll never think
about it again but if it's constantly
floating around and you feel like then i
can buy happiness or i can buy joy for
three thousand dollars more
you're not going to find it there it's
not there and it is a it's a wonderful
thing to have big we have big parties
we're we're ramsey's man we like to
party all of our weddings were huge we
love big weddings and everybody dancing
and and good food and man it's a fun
time and it is one day and it's gone it
is it does evaporate but so is travel or
so there's other things we spend money
on so right but
there is no you do know there is no
correlation between the size of the
wedding budget and the success of the
marriage though right
yes
if anything there might be a negative
correlation
yeah yeah for sure well i'm just glad
we're not going into debt for it but i
do have that guilt
you know
you know what i'm saying i'm not glad i
have i chose yeah not to go into debt
for it
mm-hmm
you're like being a grown-up and stuff
here
yeah is is the person you're about to
marry are they
guilt-tripping you
are saying man if we weren't doing it
like a wedding like this like where's
this guilt coming from
me um i guess because
we we have worked so hard the last few
years to pay off our debt and now we're
in a finally in a really good financial
spot are you kind of a taiwan you have
trouble enjoying money
yes um and and i just i'm worried that
after the wedding our cars are going to
go and we're going to need they are they
are 100 100 chance
and you know what honeymoon when i'm
going to fry in 15 years
it'll be a funny footnote to a great
wedding
yeah let this be a great experience for
you
to
you worked so hard so that
you could honor this i like that this
cool ceremony right that's why you're
going to work so hard after this wedding
to you're going to get new cars so that
you'll end up on the side of the road
you're going to work really hard to pay
off your house so that you can give
recklessly to people in your community
you're going to do these things so that
right and you all have worked really
hard to get right here i would challenge
you to dial it down to 20. absolutely
18-5 come up with a number yeah and then
just then just lock it in
and go based on that i've got to do the
dress this way
based on that i've got to do the
catering this way based on that i got to
have friends go pick some
daisies out of the farmer's field
because we don't have money for a
flourish based on that i don't know what
it is but i mean i've had folks on this
team in the last two years three years
four years
many many many of them have had some
incredible weddings for under 10 grand
yeah
but it involved it involved friends
pitching in
mom's cooking stuff for the rest i mean
involved all kinds of different things
you can do you don't have to do that
you're not doing anything morally wrong
or financially wrong if you just say the
budget's 20 and we're going to hire it
all out that's okay but my point is is
that you can have a really nice wedding
for 20k and one thing that helps me in
these moments of spend and feel guilty
is
if you you had this 25 000 budget and
you decide to roll it down to 18.5
make sure you take that gap money and
you apply it to one of these things on
the back end like i'm going to use this
for a car i'm going to use this for
those things and so you'll feel like
you're getting ahead and you're getting
this great wedding but i i'm like you
dave we've
i've seen some pretty inventive and
creative weddings over the last couple
years because of covid and they're
awesome and they're all still married
and they're not a hundred thousand
dollars in the hole no no
let me no you don't borrow for a wedding
no no no no no but she's not doing that
she's not doing that she's
what a great young lady very incredible
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today parents if you have
school-aged kids the last thing you want
is for them to be normal you want them
to be weird like we teach around here
and that's why you've already got them
listening to stuff like the ramsey show
in the back seat of your car you're
raising next gen
financial peace smart kids right hey
we're on board with this so we've got
tons of stuff to help you and even your
kids teachers in our back-to-school sale
my god back to school is here
one of the biggest challenges teachers
face is getting students to engage in a
healthy classroom conversation and
that's why dr john deloney to my right
created classroom editions
of his questions for humans conversation
starters for elementary middle and high
school kids help them build lifelong
friendships through real
in-person
conversations at home keep the fun and
learning going with the popular kids
books the adventure pack is a family
favorite
includes the story time collection
financial peace junior the smart saver
bank all for teaching kids how to handle
money if there's a teacher in your life
or your kid's life pick them up one of
the questions for humans classroom
additions as a gift for them
shop the back to school sale at
ramseysolutions.com
john i did not know you did
i probably knew it but i forgot it
classroom edition yeah for elementary
middle school and high school classrooms
elementary conversation starter sound
like
exactly is a conversation that would
happen around a lunch table here at work
[Laughter]
conversation with me you and george on a
boat
i'll just leave it at that randy's in
washington d.c hey randy what's up
i'm doing well dave how are you better
than i deserve what how can we
help president i want to say thank you
for accepting my call um
my wife and i are pretty much and i
would say a good problem to have
so i'm active duty military um
we just sold our home at the end of june
we ended up with 184 000
in equity which we used to pay off the
rest of our debt
left us with about 130 left over so we
maxed out the emergency fund
i have increased my contribution to my
tsp
uh to 15 percent like i'm supposed to in
babies and baby step four
um the problem i have is i'm up for a
promotion this year which is about a 450
um pay increase per month and what i
don't know
right now is whether i should
increase my just basically do the
percentage difference and contribute
that to my tsp
until i can retire from it or
use it for a separate account
okay cool
cool
uh i mean you can dump it into the tsp
if you want you could dump it into a
roth ira if you want are you in the roth
tsp you need to be
i am so i'm uh
and this c plan 80 and 20 i-20s
so i'm at 60 c 20 s and 20i that's good
that's the mix we teach yeah that's good
okay so you're already on track with all
that yeah i mean you're in a baby step
seven situation until you repurchase a
home are you stable in terms of your
location are you gonna buy again or are
you just waiting to quit for the
military quit moving around for you by
again
uh so right now we're going to wait
until i'm ready to retire to purchase
our forever home um that's actually like
a second part to the question so the
extra when will you be retiring
in about 10 years
okay all right yeah you need to be
dumping the rest of that with a
smartvestor pro then some mutual funds
so it will keep up with the increase in
value in real estate during that time
you don't want it sitting there making
nothing and still because 184 000 10
years from now won't buy 184 000 will
buy now
so that that that's the thing so hey man
thanks for your service but yeah i'll
load that tsp up load your roth iras up
and then load your house fund up and
that's really all you got left to do
you're just making money and doing good
good good work real quick what's it walk
me through tsp dave
what now what tsp walk me through that
what does it what a tsp what are you
asking about it walk me through what is
i'll walk you through that oh okay
it's the thrift savings plan okay it's
401k for federal federal government
employees basically okay and uh but they
have uh certain options and there have
initials on them the c is the common
stock the s is the small company
uh the i is the international that's the
three we recommend heavy in the sea
because the sea is the highest
performing of all their common options
pretty much like an index fund
it operates like an s p 500 index fund
so the tsp does pretty well and they
just recently have started offering it
as a roth
option and so fed federal employees of
any kind including military ftsp so
postal workers that kind of you'll see
it there all all the time
uh guys i want to uh
i'm not gonna pick on you about this uh
out there and you can use the word don't
i won't i won't give you a hard time but
i'm gonna say this uh
really um
because i appreciate the last caller a
bunch but there is no such thing as a
forever home except heaven i agree
okay this idea that you're going to buy
a home
uh and i learn i have the benefit that
that's going to last forever well
everything freaking changes
and so we share and i haven't moved a
lot we've moved every uh
13 to 15 years roughly uh with rare
exceptions a couple times we stayed two
years in one place but i mean our poems
that we've kept a long time but they
they survived that stage of life
and then we went to another stage of
life that was another stage of life and
then we did this is another stage of
life and so
um
i i learned this i was selling houses uh
custom-made homes we custom for a custom
home builder when i was 22 years old and
people would come in to build their
dream home
and it was kind of the first it was what
people used to say instead of saying
forever home right it's so i'm going to
build my dream home
and it was so disturbing that during the
14 or 15 months that we built their
dream home that their dream changed
that's right while they were the dream
changed while within that one year
period of time and so by the time they
moved in it was no longer their dream
yeah and it was dissatisfying so there's
just
there's
forever home is such a millennial thing
to say
just don't say that
because it's not true
well it's like you're not going to be
there forever it's like you're moving
i'm going to get somewhere and then
everything will be ah this is how life
well there's like you can figure out one
set of bricks and mortar one bedroom
arrangement one
great room kitchen arrangement and and
you know honestly kitchens and
uh living spaces are so much better than
they were 25 years ago right the designs
of homes across america are just
way better
you know it's so much more functional
and livable and enjoyable and we live
our lives differently now than we did in
those days
uh but the little house i grew up in was
like 1100 square feet and it was the uh
two and a den
which is the bedroom that wasn't sure
what it was that's right yeah it didn't
know if it identified as a dent or a
bedroom and so how many kids are there
as to what it is so yeah and a bath and
a half
and holla core doors you could hear
everything through the whole house it
was gross
and um but when you slam them they
didn't they never had the effect you
wanted if you slammed them hard enough
they just kind of came off in your hand
like also wood or something but yeah but
the uh uh but the kitchen in that house
that i grew up in my childhood was in
yeah it was perfect for that but it was
not a forever kitchen right it was a
you know when you in comparison to today
it was fine for them but in comparison
so no you're not you're not going to
find a forever home here's what here
here's what i've come to believe with
when it comes to forever home stuff and
even less than forever home for me i
keep thinking all right
when i get this house paid off i'm going
to do this with the deck i'm going to do
this out there the driveway i'm going to
build retaining wall over here and what
i have found is these are all ways to
distract me from living contently right
now
i keep thinking down the road things
will be good down the road i'll finally
get this thing down the road and if i
can learn to be content where i'm at
that changes the yeah it changes the the
tenor of my life moving forward but it's
it and and but
you're never gonna get a nice enough big
enough
great enough home to live there forever
because something's going to change or
you're going to lose your job or mom's
going to get sick or whatever by the way
it i i built this monstrosity huge home
it was everything yeah that we wanted
and we fully intended to live there the
rest of our lives because we were old
when we built it already you know and so
but we lived there 14 years
and we went you know what we're selling
it
and it was it was it's a fabulous
world-class house you know we sold it
and we got a little house a lot smaller
now and we like it a lot
it's okay i mean gosh it's just not that
big a deal
you know you're not gonna there's you
cannot build something that will change
as your life changes yes build forever
relationships not forever homes
that sounds like a little millennials uh
whatever those people's name is lying
this is the ramsey show minimalists
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org
budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage joseph
and victoria are with us welcome to
nashville guys thank you where do you
guys live uh we live in minnesota we are
about 45 minutes south of minneapolis-st
paul area fine welcome to nashville and
all the way to nashville to do a
debt-free scream how much have you paid
off
uh we are at 76 809
i love it and how long did this take you
11 months wow and your range of income
during that time uh we started right
around 60 a year and we ended at 145.
nice jumping one year
did somebody go to work that wasn't
working i did what do you do for a
living guys um i actually drive school
bus okay which is super fun too yeah
that's cool i'm a truck driver a couple
of drivers yeah you got it did you drive
from minneapolis no no we didn't we flew
you drive for a living you want to no we
have five kids so oh yeah
yeah they get interesting entire changes
and that'd be fantastic
all right guys what kind of debt was the
77 000 it was student loans for a little
bit on my part then we had a camper a
car and then a couple other random debts
that we had to pay off so just a
multitude of things what's the biggest
thing you sold nothing yeah
okay so you just busted into it yep and
you had some money in savings you threw
at it a little bit a little bit yeah how
much i would say three to five thousand
not much okay
so basically you going to work and you
threw it all on there yeah that was the
main reason i started working was to pay
off the debt and then down the road now
it's fun money i was working
just doing 80 truck driving and then uh
i would do door dash on the side wow you
guys are kicking it okay so you kicked
it all the way from 60 to 145 and that
and enables you in 11 months to pay off
77. you got it wow so what happened let
you on fire man you all went off like
fireworks uh honestly uh it's pretty
wild story i was actually debating on
whether i should commit suicide or not
um and i wanted my family to be secure
when i was gone and then just listening
to your show and hearing the bible
verses every day
i came home and talked to tori and
decided we should probably get into a
church
we found river valley up in the twin
cities
and
gave our life to
jesus christ got baptized october 31st
which is kind of a joke and a half
because our favorite holiday was
halloween for a long time
and uh
just changed our life ever since yep
amazing wow so was the financial
pressure part of
that or just other mental issues um i'm
i'm a disabled veteran
so i deal with ptsd and some traumatic
brain injury from from some of that so
wow
wow what's your healing journey been
like um you know it's uh it's been a
process i i got into a big good group of
uh guys at church uh some men's
leadership courses
um starting counseling with the va
coming up on august 1st so very good
congrats man very good it's awesome man
i'm so proud of you guys i mean the
money is is a big deal paying off 77 000
11 months yeah but you guys changed your
whole lives
and saved your life yeah in the process
and the money was just a little part of
that church right
i started out listening to this this
podcast on this radio show that's where
it started yeah so talk to us about when
he came and sat down and
as his wife um i've sat with a bunch of
folks in your situation and your wife
you knew for a long time there's a gap
here oh absolutely but then when he sits
down and says here's how big that gap
really is right that's that's a lot
right yeah and it was an eye-opener yeah
walk us through your next steps um it
was essentially just trying to batten
down the hatches so he said we have to
pay off this amount of money we have to
work with this amount of money so we
went from having a grocery budget with
five kids of you know 150 200 a week
down to 75 to 100 a week so it was
difficult but we managed to do it you
know cutting down our cell phones
cutting cable cutting everything we
possibly could to fit everything in this
budget while paying off as much as we
could
so it was a huge jump but it was
definitely doable
that's amazing i want to make sure i get
the
order of the occurrences
so you started listening to the show
correct yep um then you started
attending church correct yep and then
you started working on the debt yep we
had to get our ducks in a roll yeah yeah
in a way we i started listening to the
show we started working on the debt and
then after a while of that we plugged
into church oh okay
okay so it was kind of all mixed in
together right i couldn't i couldn't get
i couldn't figure the timeline okay wow
wow
it's powerful sounds like a good church
it's a very good church it's amazing
river valley is definitely a blessing to
the twin cities yeah absolutely
yeah and
you are a blessing to the twin cities my
man
he absolutely is there's a lot a lot a
lot of men right now who are sitting
down
driving a truck mowing their yard with
their headphones in listening to this
conversation and they have begun to tell
themselves the people around me would be
better if i wasn't here yeah absolutely
too many men tell themselves that and
you had the courage to say something out
loud and now you're able to inspire
millions of people because of your
courage and bravery and
the journey's still going and you're
still meeting with men and you're still
going to counseling like
mandy i
i was in honor of your service as a
veteran
i am equally if not more in honor of
your service as a civilian saying here's
who i'm going to be and this is what
this looks like man that's bravery and
courage and i'm proud of you thank you
we're glad to know there's men like you
in our community it's awesome and women
who will
that don't have a school bus to get us
out of that that's right man there's a
couple of rock stars up there wow you
guys are amazing
beautiful amazing you have really become
heroes and changed your lives
i'm so proud of you
very very very well done what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
daddies
you just gotta start go drive a school
bus yeah go drive school bus it's
actually really fun i know i'm not
putting it down
a lot of people do they think how do you
do that i'm like you just do it yeah
it's fun well you like people and kids
oh absolutely i love kids yeah i had a
school bus driver that hated people in
kids
1960s and 70s where they had a cigarette
hanging out of their mouth while they're
driving right
you people shut up back there yeah you
know that kind of thing right so hey but
a good bus driver will spot those two
kids to get on the bus that have nobody
and you will be their light for their
whole
like i have a few of them like that yes
you do that's awesome good for you guys
stopping the uh who was it the other day
tell me about the bullying on the school
bus yeah wow yeah that's a big deal way
to go you guys so what do you tell
people the key to getting out of that is
you just got to start start you got to
start you got to start
starts in your head and then through the
process
it moves to your heart it goes to
an everything i got mentality to a
whatever it takes mentality yeah so with
the journey you've the heart journey
you've been on
um
suicide jesus
getting out of debt a lot of
transformation in your heart
in a short period of time um
talk about how that feels to because i
mean you you did a complete double
backflip here man
um
you know it's uh it's calming
you know it's uh
there's nothing to worry about
yeah this everything everything's
already taken care of you just gotta go
out and make it happen right
there's a word we use around here called
peace yeah absolutely yeah the day we
paid off our last day i was like oh my
god financial
university yeah wow wow that really is
very cool well we've got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you that's the
next chapter in your story i want to
hear back from you and hear how your
journey's going absolutely all right
write in and tell us an email we'll read
it and keep everybody up today you guys
are
very very impressive you have come a
very long way in a lot of areas in a
very short period of time right
your income your your debt your
spiritual walk your mental health
everything is pretty impressive yeah so
um got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you total money makeover for you
give that to somebody get them started
financial peace university a one-year
membership to that get you going in that
and that's got the new videos in it that
include dr dalony and george campbell
and rachel cruz and me and all right
let's bring the kiddos up you said
there's five of them what are their
names and ages we have mason who's 16
madison and michaela who are 13.
maya is six
and maverick is three all right wow lots
of m's they're all m m's they're a
handful of m m's
i love it very cool well done have they
been practicing a debt-free screen
absolutely so the whole gang knows how
to do this because they know their
family tree was changed yes all right
well we're so proud of you and thank you
for your service and we're proud of you
guys being heroes count it down let's
hear a debt free scream ready three
two
one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
man oh man oh man dave i've suddenly got
allergies in my eyes this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today chad is in augusta georgia
hi chad how are you
good sir how you all doing better than
we deserve man what's up
oh yeah i'm just calling and i'm uh i
have i have a
mortgage just about ready to pay at all
good but i'm a real estate agent and you
know with a real estate agent you got to
kind of go get it i love going to get it
but it's a big chunk
and i'm just like i think i'm there but
i'm looking for i guess maybe a final
confirmation with retirement that i have
what's in place to pay it off i've been
a fan of yours for probably 20 years and
i've hit bumps along the way to get my
house paid off and now i'm at a position
so what do you want
95. how much cash do you have
do eleven
good lord pay it off take it off what
are you doing
pay it off today you don't need to think
about this you knew what i was gonna say
jacob's in fort worth hey jacob welcome
to the ramsay show
hot dog is this really happening it's
happening what's up
hey so uh
my
uh in-laws bought a house in 2018 for
280 000 and they're offering to sell it
to us now for what they paid for it then
um
and since it's a non-arms league
purchase we're wondering who we need to
hire to help us uh make that happen
okay so
they're selling you the house at a below
market price
yes and are you getting a mortgage
uh yeah we were also wondering uh what
would be the best way to pay for it and
you have a down payment in cash
uh not yet we're moving in their tenants
just moved out we're planning to rent
for six months to a year to build up uh
down payment okay um work with a
mortgage company to establish what
you've got to do to do that so that you
do that properly
and then the mortgage company will
require a formal closing
with an appraisal
a survey
title insurance
all the things that you've got to do
anyway the title company that the
mortgage company who can hook you up
with to do the closing can also then
simply prepare the deed
okay the vast majority of the paperwork
done at that closing will be around the
mortgage
all right but you just need a deed in
addition to that a warranty deed in most
states is what it will be
and um
but this is arm's length there's no
weird family crap
like you can't figure out you're not
allowed to buy christmas presents for
five years because you bought this from
them or something they don't have any
strings attached right
yeah no strings touched
real healthy people mentally
yes okay all right
so um just trying to help us out yeah
and they're not going to like say you
shouldn't have got you shouldn't have
bought that car
uh no we don't like what you do with the
flooring
i don't think so no all right all right
just checking because you know this is a
dangerous thing so sometimes that
discounted price comes out of your
backside instead of your wallet what
comes out of your yeah it comes out of
out of your soul
exactly and affects your relationship
with their daughter your wife and so on
so yeah just want to make sure all that
if that's all good but the transaction
is fairly simple uh while you're getting
uh
i will tell you to get a uh
a title policy the mortgage company will
require to get you to get a mortgage
title policy that usually in most states
you can get what's called a simultaneous
issue and you get an owner's title
policy as well
while you're at it
the title company
in order to execute on the mortgage
probably will require a sales contract
be developed but they probably have a
form you can just fill out and do that
okay so it's really
most of the
uh
detail
crap will be handled by the mortgage
company and their tight and the title
company that they recommend to get
everything done you'll add to that
probably a sales contract an owner's
title policy and a which will probably
be 50 bucks or 100 bucks or something
and
then uh you'll add to that the deed and
in most states that's called a warranty
deed i don't know what it is in texas
but i imagine it is so uh
the that's the actual title to the
property and then the more the title
company will charge a closing fee
and the recording fee to record
the mortgage or the deed of trust
depending on the state and then they
will also can record that warranty deed
to you the warranty deed is of no value
until you record it at the courthouse
and that's every state
and so if you don't if you're if you're
walking around with a deed to your house
in your pocket you don't own the house
yet
unless or until it has been recorded at
your local courthouse
the courthouse
the recording of the deed at the
courthouse is how ownership is
established and transferred so that's
what you want to make sure that goes
through but that's a fairly basic thing
that any title company doing the
mortgage will help you do
and probably automatically tell you
everything that they're doing and all
that it's most title companies in
america do a really really good job or
closing attorneys or whoever's doing the
real estate closing
which if it's a closing attorney they
probably sell title insurance so it's
all it's all tied in together there very
very cool
good good situation that's a great
situation kyle is with us kyle is in
chicago hey kyle what's up
hey dave i'm good how are you better
than i deserve how can i help i'm good
hey uh i got a job offer to uh
increase this uh
lateral move from two companies but
company a i've got a i got a loan in my
401k
and i think that's going to hinder my
move um
i want to move because it's a
substantial increase in pay
um but i don't know what to do or how to
make this happen how much is the 401k
loan uh it's 15 000
okay and what's the increase in pay
uh about a hundred thousand dollars
lord
that's nice
what do you make now
uh one 101 and you're going to make 201
about 200 yes so yeah
what do you do for a living
um engineer
nice job well done man
were you being underpaid before are they
overpaying you
maybe a little bit
maybe a little bit of both i guess
is there any signing bonus at all
um i could ask for one and that's what i
thought about doing but
i don't want to be cooked on that you
know what to say just tell them you got
a 15 000 401k loan you need to clear can
they give you that much of an advance
and take it out of the next three take
it out the next three checks
okay that could work yeah and that that
just takes care of it because you go if
you don't repay this loan in full within
60 days of leaving it's considered an
early withdrawal and you're going to get
hammered with taxes and penalties that
are going to make you wish you've done
something
okay yeah so you do need to take care of
it i i you know you've already have one
kind of debt
if you move it to a different kind of
debt over to a credit union loan that's
okay
but my preference would be that the new
employers somehow help you make this
move if i were bringing you on and i
could advance your 15k
um
against your next
three months pay or whatever or four
months pay and take it out of that where
you can still eat during those months
but still get my money back pretty quick
as the employer i would do that
okay cool yeah like they said the change
the increase in pay is definitely going
to help me pay other you know other debt
off but i just was worried about this
you know probably not you get this
unless they take if they take this out
of your future check because they
advance it it may take you maybe your
get out of debt plan starts after that's
done right because you may need that you
may need to eat but against 200 grand
five thousand over three months is
that's not a big chunk
yeah it should it should be okay yeah
should be okay should be very very
doable but yeah sometimes you just um
just say uh
look we got a deal but i have a problem
can you help me solve this problem
so as an employer would you think less
of me if i came to you with that
challenge no
no as long as you don't come in
demanding and belligerent about it like
i gotta have that you know but instead
uh help me solve a problem yep i would
love to help you solve a problem you're
a new team member
i'm bringing you on to you know i am
you know i'd love to do that you know i
don't have the money to move so we pay
relocation expenses you know i mean it's
whatever there's problems to be solved
when you're hiring people sometimes
especially in this market where we've
got almost no unemployment yeah um and
so uh
you know that they they probably are
real happy he's coming well clearly for
doubling him up clearly they're adding
100 to what he was making so they're
pretty they're pretty happy that's
important to say if they say no go down
to the local credit union clear this
thing yeah get that thing
and then just put that in your debt
snowball and knock it out that's right
yeah that's simple the good news is you
got an extra 100k to knock out your dead
snowball now real quick ding ding baby
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice we
help people build wealth do work that
they really love and create actual
amazing relationships number one
best-selling author
and host of the doctor john delaney show
ramsey personality john deloney is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five
one of the benefits of this show being
where it has been for 30 years in the
city of nashville is occasionally we
have uh actual big time stars drop in
who also happen to be friends uh john
rich of big and rich uh save a horse
ride a cowboy
fame is
he and joan are good friends of sharon
and mike drop by and uh he's got a
rather interesting story you've engaged
in my cousin hello well done brother
well thank you sir well done you are a
uh you are a juggernaut without a doubt
and i've always pulled off some fun
stuff you and i have talked many times
on the air and many more times off the
air about this stuff um
including the whole redneck riviera
movement and the whole the whole process
but many years ago you've written and
produced some songs and uh multiple
multiple number ones over the years many
years ago you moved away from
the um
well the
industry the industry the radio industry
the labels the publishers and all that
and and the world that we're in today
allows you to just get direct access to
the consumer
and um consequently you wrote a song
so mike rowe and you this last time we
talked i was talking to mike the other
day about this yeah um wrote a song
santa's got a dirty job that one went to
number one for about about a hot minute
yeah back at christmas and uh now you
got another number one without a label
how do you do this right well the the
people are responding uh which is a
great thing to see
i was uh
just so struck by the intense irony
that all the things happening in our
country right now that are so negative
are being perpetrated on us under the
banner of the word progress this is a
progressive idea this is progress uh
trust us it's gonna be fine
let's send gasoline through the roof you
need to be driving an electric car
anyway trust me it's good for you
progress progress and i thought man that
is
that's the opposite of what i would call
progress the things i see going on in
our country so i sat down and i wrote
this little three-minute straight ahead
country song called progress
and i wrote it actually the beginning of
the year and i waited to see what the
summer was going to look like and i saw
this poll that came out in early july
that said 88 percent of americans agree
and i went wow that's a big statement
under its own
they agree that the country's on the
wrong track
i said 88 of americans i said that's
conservatives and liberals and moderate
that's everybody i said it's time to put
the song out so
instead of going with the regular big
platforms
twitter facebook and youtube um i went
with true social and rumble which are so
much smaller than the ones i just listed
obviously they're fledgling level at
this point i said let's just see if i
can beat the machine
without using the machine let's see if
it's possible to do it we put it out
within six hours of it coming out the
thing was the number one most downloaded
song not just in country but in all of
music and it has stayed there to this
very second it's still sitting at number
one and there's there's people like
lizzo and billy eilish and harry styles
and the biggest artists in the world
are down below me i don't have a record
deal it's not number one because i'm
singing it i can promise you that it's
number one because of what it says and
it's it's connecting with people on a
very deep level and people are sharing
it like crazy and you've got a lot of
media on it a lot of people it became a
news story yeah because you've done it
without a label but also the the
statement in the lyrics uh progress is
not progress i mean right the hook line
is stick your progress with the sun
don't shine yeah
which is a that's about the nicest way
you could say that dave and i didn't
cuss at anybody i didn't i didn't do
anything terrible it's not like a kid
rock song or something it's
i said it in a nice country boy kind of
way but we've had enough and a song says
uh stick your progress with the sun
don't shine keep your big mess away from
me and mine if you'd leave us alone well
we'd all be just fine so stick your
progress with the sun don't shine and i
think what's happened is the moves that
have happened recently
have stepped so far outside of political
differences it's more like just personal
you have to do this or you can't go to
work you have to do this
you're
we're the parents when your kids are at
school not you we're going to tell your
kids what we want them to know they
stepped into our lives to such a degree
under the banner of progress i
me for one i'm just not going to accept
that anymore and i push back with this
song and it seems to be becoming quite
an anthem for people that feel the same
way yeah yeah it's especially
devastating for dave uh he's a huge
billy eilish fan you don't know this
no doubt and so he can't wear a shirt
around right now because the song is
just
messed up shaves good time yes massive
harry styles fan totally just yeah
watermelon sugar high that's dave
all day all day i have no idea who these
people are you too
i've got a middle schooler otherwise i
wouldn't either i do i do know who john
rich is though
well it's it's battling man it's it's
it's still at number one but these
artists these artists that are
underneath me they're 100 times bigger
than me so this is really just people
like who are listening right now if you
want to you want to see that sucker stay
at number one it's a buck 29 it's not a
big thing go download it on itunes and
if you want to see can you beat the
machine without bending the knee that's
what i wanted to find out
and thanks for all the support we've
been able to do it yeah now there's
there's a whole bunch of us figuring
that out right now because um this idea
that you will comply
right to the mob's
total and totalitarian rule
um you will comply
uh with your virtue signaling and if you
do not we will squash you like a bug
right uh is a very real thing out there
yes and uh it's something that everyone
that's in the public eye is navigating
uh companies are navigating it people
that are in the public eye are
navigating it where ramsay we have to be
wise and principled
uh
and decide which fight we want to pick
where is it we want to stir up a ruckus
you know and we want to be intentional
about it and so but it's it's a lot
different than even three years ago or
even five years ago the environment the
toxic environment and the culture is out
of control hey john let me ask you this
um we have one most common questions i
get from young authors people who want
to be songwriters how do you do this and
how do you write something
everyone thinks you got to have a deal
you got to go with the big machine you
got to go get a group of this and you
had something that was on your heart
that said no i want to put i want to put
this out there and obviously you're a
good
singer or someone you know how the the
recording process works but what would
you tell that young person with an idea
who thinks they have to go
this quote-unquote traditional route
to make it to be heard to to do what i
want to to say what i want to say right
well i think today's point earlier we
have routes now to get directly to the
people it really comes down to your
content at that point yeah if you come
with something you could be somebody
we've never heard of before but if you
come with something that is that is
inspiring enough that hits hard enough
uh and it starts getting passed around
it can turn into an absolute avalanche
let's let's fire the song we want to
hear it as we go into the break
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a hole in this country where
it's hard used to be
and no glory is divided on fire in the
street they say building back better
make america
great
if that's a wave of the future all i've
got to say stick your progress
where the sun don't shine keep you a big
mess
wait for me and my name is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
last couple of years real estate
market's been tough we've all felt it
if you're scared well you don't have to
be the market seems crazy it has slowed
down but it's not going to crash
if you're ready to buy it's a good time
to buy if you're ready to sell it's a
good time to sell
it's just not as wild and crazy and
white hot as it was a few months back
so what you've got to have somebody with
knowledge and skill to help you navigate
this this is not amateur hour
you need a high octane high protein real
estate agent if you're going to list a
house right now this is an excellent
time to list a house but you need to get
in touch with one of our endorsed local
providers that are ramsey trusted these
are agents that are high producers they
know what's going on they've got their
finger on the pulse they're doing lots
and lots of transactions every month
it's not your uncle charlie who just got
his dad gum license don't list your
house with your uncle charlie who just
got his license that's dumb because
you're going to put your largest asset
that you own with a newbie with a
beginner
don't do that
get somebody that knows what they're
doing ramsay solutions.com
agent get with one of our elps that are
ramsey trusted ramsey solutions dot com
slash
agent lisa is in grand island nebraska
hi lisa welcome to the ramsey show
hi thank you it's an honor to speak with
you both you too what's up i have a
thank you i have
maybe a couple of questions
my husband and i i'm 60 and he's 63
and we have about 30 000 left on our
mortgage and i am wondering if we could
uh take 15 000 out of our roth and 15
000
out of our 401k to just kind of rip the
band-aid off how much is in your roth
total
um now it's about 5 20.
why don't you just take it all out of
the wrong
well
401 k is 50 and our roth is at 22. 22
000.
yes yeah
and the the balance on the mortgage was
30
yes well you've gained money in savings
that's not in retirement
um d savings how much is in that
uh 15
okay
all right
i'd probably clean out that roth just
for simplicity
okay that's 22 of it
and then pull the rest out of your 401 k
and you're going to pay taxes on that
but no penalties
okay and i'd be debt-free like by the
end of the week
oh good all right because my our advisor
is kind of thinking that we're not going
to have really enough to get us through
if 30 000 keeps you from getting through
when you have 525 000 in your account
your advisor is an idiot
okay i feel much better i mean think
about it you're not if you're 30 000
off
you got other problems
i think a great gift you could provide
your um advisor would be to swing by a
cvs and pick up a calculator and
when you go visit you could just hand
that with a bow on it it's an
old-fashioned thing that people used to
use yeah
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings free
samples free shipping new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best deal all right today's question
comes from jason in texas jason writes
i've been a huge fan for 20 years but
have not been able to implement any of
your strategies because
just take a pause right there
my wife thinks tithing and the rest of
your methods are too restrictive she
stopped going to church a long time ago
and refuses to forgive me for things
that happened in our past
the ministers that i've consulted with
say she is emotionally and spiritually
abandoned me years ago
oh man my 18 year old watches your
videos and loves them she keeps asking
why didn't you and mom do all this stuff
it seems to work really well i'm trying
to explain why but don't want to throw
her mom under the bus
is there a way a 52 year old can start
over in life and help a daughter be a
calm all she can be
yes
as our i do it all the time yeah all the
time
um
i don't want to minimize jason i don't
minimize your pain
here's what your daughter really needs
um to quote our friend jocko
she needs you to take ownership
uh you look back over your life and it's
because your wife did this your wife
didn't do that it's because of this
what she needs you to say is i didn't i
made some choices along the way
and here's where i find myself and
here's what i'm gonna do
with these next steps and here's what
you can do too
and there's something about that
ownership that's really powerful
so
it sounds like there's a
a chasm
in this relationship is this due for an
ultimatum like you go see a marriage
counselor um and you say
uh i'm gonna go see a counselor and if
we can't begin to get on the same page
and resolve some of these things then
we're gonna call this
um it it the the way it writes is is
there a way to start over i was just
assuming that they've
called it yeah they've called it so
it sounds like he has the ministers have
given him permission
is in his mind right but i don't think
he's looked at her and said this is done
it's time for me to move it it's um
unless we can heal right this is done
that's right um
just zero chance of a healing or
yeah i mean if somebody if if your
spouse left you emotionally and
spiritually and physically years and
years ago
then yeah these kids have grown up in a
home and that's their picture of what
love looks like that's their picture of
what marriage and partnership and
communication and connection looks like
and so healing starts with
i didn't i should have had a hard
conversation a long long time ago and i
didn't
and this is the law the uh
basically they've been divorced they
just need to actually formalize it they
they've been divorced for a long time
and they just need to formalize they've
modeled modeled what that looks like to
their kids and so it starts with
ownership here's some choices i didn't
make right a long long time ago
um and here's the more importantly or as
importantly as here's what i'm going to
start doing now and i'd love you to join
me
and i think i think it's that
complicated that hard and that simple
yeah when we went through bankruptcy and
lost everything it
um terrorized me and traumatized sharon
um and so that's a thing i did that she
had to forgive me for in a sense because
i
basically you know she i always laugh
and say she thought she married sir
galahad turns out it was goober but um
but that's you know the the truth is she
was left um with situation but i was not
going on nor but i
there's a period of time that
we can uh recognize the terror that she
felt the trauma from having little kids
and no money in the water got turned off
because her husband's a buffoon right
okay granted but five years later we're
not still talking about that no then
she's choosing to carry that stuff
around and i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
be at the other end of that weapon
i didn't find infinite right once
i'm staying so dude 20 years ago you did
something you know after four years of
that
everything after four years is your
fault
if you choose to carry that thing around
no you know he put he he accepted
the paralyzation of the household for 16
years longer than he should have that's
right that's right he should have dealt
with her that's right a long long time
ago lack of healing that's right and it
was not that she didn't have a
valid reason for being pissed i don't
know what he did right but i know what i
did i lost everything it was my fault
sharon had no idea what was going on it
wasn't her fault i didn't hide it from
her i just didn't ask her right and she
didn't know and so she's left feeling
uh you know
uh like you're driving down the road
in the middle of the night and you hit a
patch of ice and the car starts spinning
yeah you know you're gonna hit something
you just don't know what or when and you
know and that's where she was for a year
and a half period of time as we went
down the
the the toilet financially and the round
and around we go you know and so
yeah granted and today even um you know
we've got
checks and balances in our relationship
in place so that um she's not left
feeling like i'm somehow out of control
again
because because that little seizure that
was 30 years ago that's right and uh how
old was rachel when all this happened
born baby she's a baby so when i think
about my friend rachel we've talked
about this when she has a uh emergency
fund for her emergency fund those seeds
were planted in
money could be scarce so money's a thing
right and that's those are long ago
right so she steals that attention from
her mom sit with your daughter and have
that conversation right here jason's
back one take ownership brother
yeah time past time to take ownership
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage
lorraine is with us how are you lorraine
i'm nervous but i'm good i'm i got this
i got this you got it you got it we've
never lost a patient okay good so you're
gonna be okay so we're so glad you're
here thanks for coming where do you live
thank you i'm from l.a california oh fun
welcome to nashville
how much debt did lorraine pay off i
paid off seventy thousand dollars very
good how long did that take it took me
three years good for you and your range
of income during that time i went from
219 um to 234. whoa what do you do for a
living
i
am a heavy lift
operator
i work for the ports of la and long
beach um closer to the city of san pedro
for a company uh called apl yeah yeah so
you're sitting in one of those cabs
lifting those cartons on and off the
ships all day you've had a boring few
years huh it's been hectic
it's been crazy yeah the last few months
trying to play catch up yeah wow been a
lot of work have you ever dropped one
yes yes okay i just needed to know what
was in it actually i
um not the can but the whole machine
tipped over because it was too heavy
yeah i've had you in it oh yeah
i had a rescue team come and get me out
you were in the did it go in the drink
it went in the water no no no it was on
the it was
on the yard but it was
uh not facing how many stories did it
fall over this is it i get back to the
debt in a minute but oh my gosh
it was about oh my goodness um
five high she's the reason we can't get
glass that was the one full of glass
yeah it was full of sand it was gravel
oh that's why it was really heavy and i
stack them up
they're uh 40 feet high each can so i
did
oh my god it was it's pretty high yeah
it's pretty high yeah so it wasn't a
straight drop it kind of like
yeah
yeah like a tree oh my gosh yeah
wow
and then you next day you're back in
there going again huh go and do that
again go do it 200 000 a year this is
awesome yeah so what kind of debt was
your 70 000
so
i had credit fever i had a big
relationship with my credit cards um
mostly credit cards kind of a toxic
relationship
abusive relationship yes um
i had uh two personal loans i had a car
loan
and i paid my son's um tuition on a
monthly basis you were just kind of
normal i was very 200 000 and broke very
broke so what happened what woke you up
um i just
um i had just bought my car
and i was you know excited going through
the channels i stopped listening to
music and i said i'm just listening to
you know radio uh podcasts and stuff
like that and i accidentally
heard you on one of the stations
say are you sick and tired of being sick
and tired and i was like what what is he
talking about like switched it
another time i heard it again and you
said are you living paycheck to paycheck
and i was like
what and then i
switched it again and just got following
me around what does he want what is he
talking to me
around and then the last time i heard
you you said um
you know most americans don't even have
a thousand dollars saved in their
savings and i was like
okay
he knows too much
this is too much he knows way too much
about my life like this is me and so i
tuned in your shoe size is nine and this
new car has a spy thing in it yeah
it's a tesla feature i tuned in and i
said oh my god all these years i've been
doing everything wrong
everything wrong i was told the more
money you make the more money you spend
the more money you make the more money
you spend
and that was my that was her mother's
voice did you hear it i heard a tip i
heard it
actually that was my dad's voice oh okay
my mom was that as a high voice yeah my
mom was a frugal one she was like
uh debt is the devil you know don't get
no credit cards that's horrible don't do
that don't live like that okay so she
was you know a lot more okay so you
started listening to the radio and that
that kind of you start going i've been
doing this all wrong then what did you
do you just kept listening more or you
got the book or what'd you do i got the
book
total
oh yeah okay oh yeah i i said i gotta go
get this book i need to read it i this
guy knows what he's talking about
he knows everything about everything
that i've done
[Laughter]
yeah you became my financial father and
you know and i just said wow like i
never you know my dad never really
talked to me about finances we were
raised do as you're told and don't ask
questions
so
i'm hearing you talk about your kids and
how you you know raise rachel and how
rachel's like me i'm rachel like i'm
like oh my god
he would be so mad at me plus or minus
being in a tower lifting brakes
i was like father dave would be so mad
at me right now i was like i need to
make him proud so now you did it i did
it what do you tell people the key to
paying off seventy thousand dollars yes
i say get on a budget
um getting on a budget was new to me
um i knew how much i had to pay but i
never knew
how to get it done
and the book just guided me and it took
me there
and about a year
before i almost
finished i wanted to be debt-free by the
time i was 50
but you know life happens and a lot of
things happen in my in my family that
held me back
so i um
ended up um going into your website and
i got a financial coach
and she was excellent cynthia stringer
she's watching i told her to watch me
the most beautiful voice very calming
very soothing she became my financial
therapist at the end wow and
i told her about how i felt um
i to be honest with you i didn't cut my
credit cards until i was done
because i was so
attached to them you know you do have a
wicked relationship yes
will you ever go back never you're sure
because um yeah they were abusive and
you enjoyed it
i have um five children
at home i have um
[Music]
um anthony rubin alvin anderly and alan
and elena and they
look at me
and we're we're all on the same page now
they are all
way better than i am and they
are already at their emergency fund
they're already at ten thousand so
they're doing great and you know they're
only
working you know little jobs here and
there and they're doing amazing and so i
owe that to you because you changed my
family tree oh you did yeah well you're
a hero girl with your steps and your
health hero and um you know you're used
to lifting heavy things but you lifted a
whole life change thank you pretty
important thank you yeah and don't
minimize i i watched my mom do hard
things from 40 to 50 and it's changed
generationally my kids are different
because of the work my mom did when she
was in her 40s and your kids watched
that happen and your grandkids are going
to pick up these messages about freedom
and living without
this debt so good for you it's been it
took 10 years and you changed the entire
legacy i did i did and um i'm just so
proud i
i have more than a thousand dollars
saved now i've never had that before
and after my journey um
in in january
i had um
i've always had kidney stone issues and
i had this huge kidney stone it was like
an inch and a quarter
and i had already saved
some money in my emergency fund and i
was off for a month
and i was whistling the whole time i was
just
you know recovering at peace
and it was
beautiful an emergency becomes an
inconvenience yes when you got your crap
together well done
that's incredible well done that was
great yo we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that's the next
chapter in your story for sure and
another copy of total money makeover you
can give that away when you're talking
about this sometimes and somebody says
how'd you do that total money makeover
did it it's done it for about 8 million
people by the way yeah and financial
peace university if you've not been
through it yet we're gonna give you a
membership for a year if you have been
through it give it to somebody the brand
new videos and the course plug into the
community there you get people around
you like you did with a coach and all
that changes everything in the whole
process it's pretty pretty stinking
incredible so so proud of you kiddo well
done well done
seventy thousand dollars paid off
lorraine from los angeles three years
she did it making 219 to 234 more
importantly she changed her whole life
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one i'm dead free
yeah
[Applause]
that's how that's done
boom
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day isaiah 41 10
fear not for i am with you be not
dismayed for i am your god i will
strengthen you i will help you i will
uphold you with my righteous right hand
eleanor roosevelt said do one thing
every day that scares you
there you go every time i'm on the air
with you dave
every time you're on the air with me
there you go
hey and by the way the last time i was
on the show i was with rachel and i'm
glad you prefaced this with the
scripture of the day
um this
the you know there's a bunch of
different segments here and i didn't
realize what segment we were on the last
one and all of a sudden rachel starts
talking in this old isaiah
old testament language and i heard
if you ever feel sad
and i was like what's happening to
rachel's brain
and i started turning quietly and look
and i know what's happening and then i
realized she was reading scripture the
day was fantastic
so thank you for prefacing for everybody
i thought we were losing a patient yeah
it could happen bill's in scranton
pennsylvania hi bill what's up
hey dave thanks for taking my call um my
question is uh my wife and i have been
in baby step 3b for almost two years
uh in that time we've been in the same
home we've had a second child
and you know the reason for
being in 3b was because our house was
getting too small but after all this
time we kind of decided that we were
going to stay with where we're at and
looking at the route of putting on an
addition
during that time we've
uh
saved up
roughly 70 thousand dollars and we have
about uh 150 of equity in our current
home that
you know now that we're not
selling
we're assuming we don't have access to
so just looking to see when can we
what what's our best step to get that
make that home renovation in addition
and when can we what are you going to
spend on the addition six
uh well we figured the addition would be
roughly about 130 thousand dollars
okay two story all right what's your
household income
uh my wife 150 000
and what's the home currently worth
today
um roughly 300.
okay
so what do homes on your street
generally sell for
so we have one of the smaller homes in
our neighborhood in our street um
but houses range from 350 to 450.
and um you said your current home is
worth 300.
right
you know within with the market today
yeah yeah
okay i would not renovate it i would
sell it
yeah i mean that's what we were our
original idea was two years ago it's a
better idea
here's why you're going to spend two
years of your life in hell
that's called a renovation
it's purgatory it's right next door to
hell
and um it's not hell but you can see it
from there and you can hear it and um
on top of that when you finish if you do
a good
job with the design and that's most of
the time a big if
because you're getting ready to change
this home by
30 to 40 percent
of its structure right
that's such a large renovation that's
almost like building a house
and the chances of you doing that with
good architectural
when you're done the house isn't just
weird is fairly low it's very hard to do
what you're doing well very hard
um
and if you do it well and it all comes
out perfect after you go through the two
years of hell now you have the most
expensive house in the neighborhood
which is never where you want to be
at the top of the market
so if i woke up in your shoes i would
sell that sucker
and i would go buy a house it's got the
stuff in it you want in a neighborhood
where you're in the middle or the bottom
half of the price range where you can
get the most future appreciation take
the equity out of your house the seventy
thousand put it down take out a fifteen
year fixed rate where the payment's no
more than the fourth you take home pay
and i would move to
a four hundred and fifty or five hundred
thousand dollar house you make enough
money to do that with uh 220 000 down
payment for sure and um
guess what
you don't have to go through two years
of hell
um because i can tell you man building a
house is difficult building a house
while you're living in it
is grounds for divorce
i mean it's just it's it's
jeez we can have a big fight hanging
curtain rods
building a whole hot no
no
i would not do it i i would not do it i
i am am i am i being clear about
advising against this before we before
we go to this next caller what are your
thoughts on renovating a home
yeah no sell your house man you know i
tell you the other thing is i we've done
light renovations a couple times like
while we were gone on a two week trip or
something they would come in and tear
out a wall and redo a bedroom and change
the carpet out and put hardwoods down or
something like that i mean you know
but you know some substantial
renovations but no it's not major
knockout entire things where you have to
move out of the house kind of crap
and um you know what happens about six
or eight months after i finish that we
move
i love it yeah i just i have i have a
yeah i have a thing all right brendan's
with us in idaho falls hi brendan how
are you
doing well
good how can we help
my family's preparing to move overseas
in a little over a year
what should we do now with our
possession should we start selling
things or look into long-term storage
what do you want to do with them
um
probably store them
why
why what what is so valuable about that
couch
oh yeah
probably not the couch but this is some
bigger possessions i guess
okay
well i mean there's there's two
categories of possessions
there's garage sale crap that you're
about to pay money to store
that you should have sold
and then there are things that are
family heirlooms or keepsakes that you
would never want to get rid of for any
price
of course but i wouldn't pay storage
fees for
a used couch or a kitchen kitchen table
we'll just get you another one later
unless it was grandma's kitchen table
dude i did that one time man i put a
couch in storage when i was in an
apartment and a year later that guy at
50 bucks a month i realized i'd paid 600
i mean i paid more than a new couch was
worth back then it was so ridiculous man
i would pair my stuff down as bare
minimum as you can and get rid of it and
if you have a few things that are legacy
pieces then yeah hang on to those yeah
yeah or stuff that you you know that
that you
well i mean there there needs to be a
real reason that it can't be replaced
with a better one newer one when you get
back how long you're gonna be gone
uh at least five years are you going on
the mission field or what
uh just working uh doing higher
education yeah overseas what are you
thinking about storing what what do you
want to keep
a few vehicles uh things that would be
a little difficult to get right
immediately once we look back don't
don't keep a car in storage for five
years unless it's a classic it'll
depreciate out from under you sell it
man
gotcha
uh
the car that you have now how old is it
2010
okay
so it's already 12 years old
and when you get back it'll be 17 year
old car
yep that is not a
no yeah sell it man sell that no sell
that for sure okay it there's no there's
no if there's not a sentimental a deep
sentimental hold on something there's
going to be very few things in your
household that are not going to be
ridiculously outdated when you come back
in five years five years in our world of
rapid change is an eternity
i mean can you imagine
getting a tv out of storage that was 10
years old have you seen five-year-old
pictures of yourself dave
well five-year-old pictures of me look
about the same but
yeah that's the thing i mean
five-year-old pictures of your kids i
mean things change your five-year-old
cell phone i mean anything like
everything is
five years is ancient for most things no
i would not hardly keep anything here
here's an important thing have some
money so that when you when you start
planning on your return
put some money away so that you like i
said with a sinking fund so you can walk
um land here and go buy a car yeah i
mean take the money from your cars and
stuff and park the money the money can
sit there it won't deteriorate um
assuming you don't put it in bitcoin i
mean but other than that it's going to
it's going to go up and go don't go with
it but you know put it in a savings
account it'll be there when you get back
and buy another car
and um you'll be pretty close on that
good show john thanks for hanging out
well done will austin ben zach andrew
james in the booth i am dave ramsey your
host we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
you